hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play amnesia
machine for pigs now I have been waiting
for this one for a long time it was
supposed to come out last Halloween but
it got delayed because hopefully it's
gonna be the greatest horror experience
we've ever had and if you recall a long
time ago way way back when about a year
and a half ago I started my youtube
channel by playing amnesia the Dark
Descent so to be here now is kind of
like a coming-of-age reims very very I'm
very very excited to be playing this
because this is what spawned my love of
horror games and like just launched me
into YouTube and dedicated to making
videos to entertaining you guys so thank
you guys so much for being this far with
me I mean coming along like this far
okay I got a shot up now because there's
about something's about to happen so but
seriously guys this is gonna be great
I mean frictional games is one of the
one of the best companies at horror they
know their stuff because if you think
back was it he who makes a piece of
himself removes himself from the pain of
being human
dr. Samuel Johnson now if you think back
Tammy's are the Dark Descent you'll know
that it was like the moment of Terror
please don't kill me what
okay who's killing who now
hi okay hahaha
I'm guessing that this is the machine
for pigs okay set a piggy Zen a pig down
there
can't see hard to tell
daddy daddy now this is the official
sequel to amnesia the Dark Descent it
doesn't take place during the same time
period and I don't know if the same
characters are involved definitely not
Daniel is somewhere hi know someone was
there someone opened that door where a
hell am I in a cage what the hell is
going on here
like most amnesia stories even the
custom ones
it begins hi begins with our character
waking up in a grog
okay there we go all right there's a
title and so it begins the terrifying
story unlike any other I am so excited
guys I'm so excited huh I'm gonna
imagine that there's got to be some
similar themes like hello okay I can
barely control but I am in the game now
let's see seems to be some wine spilled
on the floor some amnesiac wine okay so
this is made on a heavily modified
what happened oh I just suddenly got not
groggy and now I can actually move so
there's made on a heavily modified
version of the HP Lovecraft engine okay
I was in a bed but it seems that my bed
has been caged up I don't know why in my
dreams I see a man dressed in Jaguar
skins and feathered like a blooded saint
what came from the heart lubricated us
it crossed evil under its tread and
liberated us all the fetid Heat of the
jungle mirrored somewhere behind my
forehead my temple pounds the blood
boils in my skull it feels as if there's
something alive there a rat a damn rat
gnawing through my brains eating its way
out into the world even the law Downham
will not quell its endless hunger I hear
my children playing in the Attic but it
fills me with terror not love what
desperate thoughts are these okay there
we go I don't know what the voice-acting
gooo hi there I remember you from the
setting launcher that is a pig's head
that is not a live pig's head but that's
an ornate pig's head okay so it doesn't
seem like there's anything here and it
seems like there's actually some hello
there's actually electricity there's
electricity hi how's it going there okay
so it seems like there's some locks on
things but I'm kind of spending too much
time in here
I don't think I want to and note has
been added let's go to the journal see I
woke alone oh I wake alone to a house in
silence that missing sound of children
playing is like a darkens Facundo Pulgar
beckoning me to begin us descent to the
loam where surely only bodies may be
found no matter my children call and I
shall answer I will find them well are
your children alive or dead because
that's gonna affect how this all goes
down okay I held your hand and watch the
blood pool between your legs okay we
live long enough to see Edwin oh but not
ena I get it
I will take care of them my love I
promise you this okay so basically his
wife died during childbirth and there's
another Pig is that a pig mask or
something why why why would you have
something that darn creepy in a house
like this okay I can still run much like
an amnesia one Oh an actual bathroom
with actual lights and an actual bathtub
how nice okay see I must find a lantern
to use first I don't have my inventory
yet it seems but I imagine that I will
soon okay go up into the attic where my
kids said they were I don't think I want
to I'll think I will all right
hello little kitties I can still lean to
the left and right all right let's go
hi hey how's it going is something
behind it Zoe
what's going on in here
hmm mouki all right ha ha that's how
it's gonna be yeah that's what this game
is gonna be ah take too kindly to their
kind of gaming around here yeah I got a
note what did what what but they slept
in the Attic when they were babies in
arms and perhaps they've hidden there
now I remember I insisted upon it midway
between my bedroom and my office what
what are you talking about man okay who
okay that is just dust right that wasn't
a kakuka ghost who whose a bad man oh my
god
it is Duncan here what was that a
lantern what's all that
God I don't have it I don't have an
inventory do I is this an electric
lantern or is this one of those oily
lanterns look it's a dead pile of rats I
saw something I saw something move
something moved okay
aha well this is the UH teddy bear how's
it going teddy
all right that's creepy as hell is
definitely the creepiest teddy bear I've
ever seen in my entire life
daddy says it won't be a Christmas this
year he's much too busy nanny says we
must not disturb him he's ever so busy
he's gone for work before she wakes us
and often we are asleep before he
returns we found a bird in the garden
with a broken wing we gave it to nanny
who said it was a filthy thing and hit
it with a rolling pin
later we crept downstairs to bury the
body when everyone was asleep there was
a pig in the garden we heard it
snuffling about then daddy came and said
we had to come inside straight away it
was furious but we think he'd been
crying again so are my kids alive or
what what is going on here I had the
distinct
okay I hear that again
something's go down here something I
don't like come out wherever you are
what is this can I move this okay I can
move this alright wait hey let me see
what's down here first good there's
obviously some similar elements from
amnesia both in terms of the environment
that there's a lot of new stuff added on
way more detail in the environment was
that a real kid or what who's that a
real kid look like a kid don't be hiding
from Daddy
what's with the masks there's got to be
a flashback or something I don't know
what this is
what's with the masks why are they
everywhere and why did a kid sound like
there's some at the real apparition if
this games gonna use big words I'm gonna
use big words too hello hello why are
the cribs stored in the Attic why it's
all of this in the Attic
why teddy bear tell me your secrets okay
alright carrying on man this is some
house there's actually like rooms up in
the attic and yes I said rooms okay
that's how you're supposed to say room
hello yes he said I know these ruins he
was a shabby fellow all rotten with the
malodorous disease I caught him looking
at me strangely as if what he won really
wanted to know was how I knew of them
biting back the temptation to box his
ears for the impudence I simply smiled
and told him that my family's library
contained intriguing travel books the
illiterate oaf did not understand that
of course he agreed to lead us anyway I
have told the children truly this will
be an extraordinary adventure if those
old stones hold the financial benefits I
predict will be merely the first of many
alright then like I said before maybe I
didn't I'm not sure I'm gonna be taking
my time through this adventure I'm
definitely gonna be soaking in the
atmosphere
daddy what why is the Attic lead to here
okay seems like they put some bars on
doors that may be unnecessary or maybe
this is reality starting to fall apart
maybe I'm actually insane I don't know
it's hard to tell
well ain't that just a nice painting
okay what's going on down here get a
money very cool this do yes useful okay
you have one of those wonderful
composite bills but never of course I'll
buy different it's my own design
professor along with everything you see
okay you sure you understand of course
whether mr. e sent me yeah they have
concerns
okay was that it okay here piano playing
bye okay I didn't mean it or anything
leave it out about oh man
silly Ben remember from Super Mario 64
when you go up to that piano and his
search clamoring at you
bang bang bang huh I had a flashback to
that all of a sudden all right oh man I
got the volume way turned up so that
sent chills down my spine okay let's see
what's in here
something good I hope maybe something
bad it looks like the doors have changed
up am I still in the same house or what
is going on this is either an extremely
large house or him okay
I'm not used to there being a telephone
in uh amnesia here hang on I gotta check
the drawers sorry to have it I've always
done it must keep doing it I got a note
what it haha the bank is refusing credit
the ignorant swine there's a lot of
references to pigs here I'm picking up
with your button-down I sit alone in
night and weep once the children and
servants are safely asleep when they
cannot hear me my darling how I need you
now they say I have squandered my
fortune that my investment in these
latest machines is ruined the family
name what that I was to remain a local
butcher what are those two arms compared
to the multitude that can be applied
without pay without tire by adapting the
mechanisms we find in the looms in the
mills but if the bank has its way it
will all come to nothing if they come
for the house I swear I will kill them I
will kill them all I will take my rifle
my rifle this is actually before the
other one the other one was 1899 okay
wait a minute I got a note the weeping
rooms where once we sat to weep Lily's
passing on the weapons that cannot slay
the Angels to retrieve her from heaven
look beyond the paintings Oswald where
once you watch her bathe the children
must have discovered those secret places
and taken
refuge there hello hello hello precious
eagle cactus fruit help us what was that
a gunshot what just happened
did someone just shoot themselves in the
face let me guess
has the things different now what the
hell is going on here this won't even
open Oh Oh what did i do what did I do
Oh what's going on hang on what's going
on hey you can't just leave me hanging
like that what's going on what the whoa
what's happening what's going on
I'm so confused and kind of worried Oh
what okay here wait I hear wind rustling
outside I supposed to use a window no
whoa what the hell
this door is now blocked up I can't get
through here stuck okay so there's got
to be something else right right I mean
it wouldn't just stop me there would it
would it have no idea I'm so under
Lincoln for you my gun oh there we go my
rifle my rifle what a clue that it huh
what is this do
what the hell that I could sworn I saw
blood on that kids face I coulda sworn I
saw blood on that kids face I'm not
digging why wasn't that before that was
not there before okay can't fool me
replacement it's dissatisfactory so like
a pump better the intestinal canal like
a tapeworm I'm already hosting intrusion
in the breed brass better than copper
more resistant filling its own to bode
hold marrow pipe removal with needle
potential composite replacement
straightforward will respond to electro
Matic inducement to increase yield rate
serum provides accelerated resetting
resulting in naturalised movement within
two to three days subjects still require
severing of frontal lobes to reduce
emotional distress upon reactivation
damn damn it damn this wretched soul if
only it were clockwork what does that
even mean what is that even Oh what what
was that what was that what did you just
do
oh okay what the hell is going on here
this dawning people okay Age of Reason
right
an empire drone fad director for the
bleeding uh okay so you were definitely
watching people bathe you pervert okay I
don't know what those switches do but
there's a door open here boys that what
was that
what's going on okay okay we're leaving
there and Lily's honor a banquet we will
fasten that great mouth down over the
chimney and inhale the world and suck
the fairies in the nonsense clean from
your dirty heart haha what the hell is
going on I'm so confused
okay obviously the first level is gonna
be setting this theme in the tone for
the rest of the game and that theme is
gonna be horrible oh man I mean oh man
there's gonna be such great game okay I
think that's gonna do it for the first
part so I'm so excited I'm so excited oh
man
nothing like amnesia especially
something totally new like this gives
that sense of creep that little tingle
down your spine as you know there's
something lurking in the darkness beyond
the mind shatters and all is gonna be
great so I'm gonna end this part here so
thank you all so much for watching click
the annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye
what
but